You obviously need a very good
model train on a lot of data
to get this kind of result.
And it's likely that the model that
you're training in the assignments
is just not trained with
enough data to show this.
But you can try.
There are many other ways to learn
embeddings that I won't cover.
Now, that we have models for
individual words,
how do we deal with the fact that
text is actually a sequence of words?
So far, your models have only looked
at inputs that were a fixed size.
Fixed size means you can always
turn things into a vector, and
feed it to your neural network.
When you have sequences
of varying length,
like speech or text,
you can no longer do that.
Now what?